irre verfolgungsjagd in hamburg und man
muss wirklich fragen was hat sich die
polizei da gedacht ein streifenwagen mit
blaulicht und martinshorn schleudert
über den rasen des parks rammt fasst die
eigenen laufenden kollegen und nimmt
dann mit schneller fahrt die verfolgung
eines jungen mannes auf warum
aufgrund der chor ohne regeln wir haben
mit dem mann gesprochen der mit dem
handy dieses video aufgenommen hat all
das polizeiauto zähnen wie bei einer
schwer verbrecherjagd dieses video sorgt
für diskussionen in ganz deutschland was
hier los ist fragt sich auch jakob es
der 18 jährige verantwortlich für diese
bilder trifft sich heute exklusiv mit
bild wird sich auf der band gerade mit
einem freund von mir und wir haben 40
dass das nord team frauen im hintergrund
und die polizei heraus kürzlich über die
wiese verfolgt einen 17 jährigen jungen
der sich wundern die krone
beschränkungen gehalten hat und und
verfolgte ihn durch den park der
streifenwagens leider durch den
jenischpark im feinen elbvorort
othmarschen shiraz das fahrzeug dem
jungen mann hinterher der sich nicht an
masten pflicht und kontakt
beschränkungen gehalten hatte voll durch
eine coole der unterboden natürlich
beschädigt ohne rücksicht auf verluste
hauptsache dem verdächtigen hinterher
zum einen wurden fast seinen kollegen
unkontrolliertem trifft verletzt und zum
anderen wurde der junge mit einem
abstand von gerade mal ein bis zwei
metern verfolgt da hätte schon sein
können dass bei einem sturz wird
zuschauen gekommen
gefährlich war die aktion ganz sicher ob
sie verhältnismäßig war wird im netz
heiß diskutiert wer nicht sieht dass
hier gewaltig was aus dem ruder läuft
sieht gar nichts mehr
da stellt sich die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit
diese beamten haben maß und mitte
komplett verloren
auch das verständnis der jugendlichen
hält sich in grenzen so solche aktion
verliert die polizei meiner meinung nach
zu nimmt die akzeptanz hier in der in
diesem jungen gruppen und dadurch laufen
dann hat einfach die jugendlichen
automatisch weg wenn sie sehen dass sie
wegen jeder kleinigkeit eine
ordnungswidrigkeit angehängt bekommen
die polizei unter druck die polizei
sieht dieses eine video dem blickwinkel
den man auf diese perspektive hat auch
kritisch das werden wir definitiv
nachbereiten
aber das machen wir in ruhe und werden
das nicht sofort in fünf minuten machen
die jagdszenen in hamburg der grund kein
schwerverbrechen sondern lediglich ein
corona verstoß die verhältnismäßigkeit
in jedem fall fraglich
[Musik]
ein unglaubliches video war dass
deutschland jetzt diskutiert und wir
wollen darüber jetzt sprechen mit
christoph ploß er ist chef der cdu in
hamburg heraus was haben sie als
allererstes gelacht hat sie diese
aufnahmen gesehen haben
ja ich habe auch gedacht ist jetzt
wirklich maß und mittel völlig verloren
gegangen denn man kann wirklich in den
vergangenen tagen zunehmend beobachten
dass einige bürgermeister dass auch
einige landesregierung mittlerweile
nicht mehr verhältnismäßig handeln
einige beschlüsse sorgen genau dann für
solche entwicklungen und solche szenen
und meine sorge ist dass dadurch auch
die sinnvollen kohler maßnahmen an
akzeptanz verlieren und deswegen möchte
ich auch hier appellieren an die
bürgermeister und an die landesregierung
in deutschland maß und mitte bei den
beschlüssen zu wahren
was glauben sie herr plus was löst das
bei den menschen aus diese bilder wir
haben die empörung im netz gesehen aber
gerade in diesen zeiten brauchen wir das
zusammenhalt und vertrauen
absolut also solche sehen die hätten
überhaupt nicht bei der bekämpfung der
pandemie weil sie eben dafür sorgen
werden dass die menschen irgendwann
sagen wir haben die nase voll
wir akzeptieren die gesamten corinna
maßnahmen nicht mehr und dann ist meine
große sorge dass sich das virus weiter
ausbreitet und dass dann die politik
auch mit sinnvollen maßnahmen nicht mehr
zu den menschen durchdringen und
deswegen müssen wie gesagt
landesregierung und bürgermeister maß
und mittel waren das ist von enormer
bedeutung in den nächsten wochen maß und
mitte waren es ist ein gutes wort zu
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie sich
heute für uns zeit genommen haben mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren